- Hey, I'm hanging with Rainn Wilson
on Skype, give it up!
(crowd claps and cheers)
You now, my next guest
from "Days of Our Lives,"
"Melrose Place" and "The Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills."
Since then, she's become a
successful entrepreneur whose
beauty line launches November 30th.
It's called Rinna Beauty.
Please welcome Lisa
Rinna, everybody! (claps)
(crowd claps and cheers)
(mellow, resonant music)
- Thank you, what's up?
Hello, everybody!
Oh my gosh, this is so fun.
Hi, Rainn! (laughs)
- Have y'all met before?
- Hi, Lisa.
- I don't think we've ever met, have we?
I don't think so.
- Oh, we have.
- [Lisa] We have, when?
- We have, on some red carpet.
Yeah, on some red carpet, I
think you interviewed me once.
- [Lisa] Oh yes, yes!
- I remember meeting you.
- Yes, yes.
- And being struck
by your magnificence.
- Oh my God.
- It was an honor.
- How sweet is that?
- I'm struck by your outfit right now.
Those pants are fiy-ah!
- These pants are fabulous.
I've been waiting to be able to wear them,
so I'm so glad
(laughs)
that I could debut them on
"The Kelly Clarkson Show"!
- You're like, "I've been
stuck in sweats in my house."
- Come on, are we not excited?
And look, we both have silver hoops.
- We do.
Actually, I didn't even know.
Candace put them in, but
yes, they're silver. (laughs)
- They're silver, Kelly. (laughs)
- So wait, Rainn and I were just talking
about impulsive online purchases.
- Ugh.
- So have you ever fallen
or did you fall into the
trap during quarantine?
And have you ever thought about purchasing
a human brain replica?
(crowd laughs)
(laughing)
- Well,
actually, no, I've never.
Is that your human brain?
- And he's petting it!
- Okay.
Well--
- Rainn's wife
is now my favorite human on the planet.
- [Lisa] So that was
a gift from your wife?
- Yes!
- Wow.
- No no, that's a gift from him
to her.
- This was for my wife.
- Oh, that's for your wife!
- Yeah, it's from him to her.
- God bless your wife.
(laughing)
- No, she asked for it.
- Shut up.
- She was like, "Man, I want a brain."
And I was like, "This
is the greatest wife."
You have the greatest wife.
She's my favorite human.
- Wow.
- I am telling you I
got treated very special
for giving her this gift.
- Yeah you did! (claps)
- Wow.
- Very special.
- Okay, I'm really impressed.
- (laughs) Extra snuggles.
- I love that, but I don't want a brain.
No, I definitely don't.
- Okay, okay.
- Of course, I've had
many impulse purchases.
Of course.
- Yeah.
- During COVID, I bought a
print, two prints of pills.
So--
- What?
- Yes, I know it sounds crazy.
They are literal, it's a pill
and Kylie Jenner has them on her wall.
I saw a picture and I thought,
"Well, that's kind of fabulous."
On our show, "The Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills,"
I debuted my pill bag.
I carry a pill bag and I
always have in a Ziploc bag
since I've had kids, just so I have--
- My sister does that, she's
like a walking pharmacy, just
in case something happens.
- I am a walking pharmacy.
Yes!
- Yeah.
- Exactly, so I thought it
might be cute to have pills
on our wall in our movie room.
(laughs)
Right?
Doesn't everybody want pills
on their wall in their movie room?
I don't know.
- I think it's awesome.
- I do too.
- That's a great impulsive buy.
It's not as cool as the brain.
I'm gonna give you
points, Dwight. (laughs)
- Yeah, it's certainly different than--
- Oh my God, I just called you Dwight.
That really just happened. (laughs)
(crowd laughs)
- I wanna know about your movie room.
- It's not that special, actually.
You just build it, you
just get a big, huge couch,
you know, 'cause I have teenagers.
So we got this big, big, big, huge couch
that literally 10 people could be on, 12.
And then you get a big, huge
TV, the biggest TV you can buy.
- [Kelly] Yeah, and movie room, boom.
- And you have dark shades,
and I have a popcorn machine
and I have candy.
- And pills.
- And pills, and that's all you need.
(laughing)
It's really not that hard.
- You're like, "I did it overnight."
So wait, speaking of online, did you get
into the TikTok dances,
like the challenges?
- What do you think? (laughs)
- [Kelly] I feel like you would
nail it.
- I did.
Well, no, I tend to do my own
thing 'cause they're hard!
- Yeah, I tried to do one
thing that the show tried
to get me to do, that Normani did.
- Hard.
- And I was like first of all,
I should never do anything
that Normani tries,
ever.
- Well, none of us should,
by the way.
- Yeah,
it was like bouncing a basketball.
It had to land on my
butt, I'm like "What?"
(stammers) I didn't know, I don't know,
but yeah, what did you do?
- Well, my girls talked me into doing
that Megan Thee Stallion
dance that everybody did.
- [Kelly] I don't know that one.
- What's it called again,
what's the song called?
You guys know what I'm talking about.
- [Kelly] (gasps) Wait, is that you?
Oh God, you better get
it, you better get it.
- (laughs) Yeah, that's me.
(crowd exclaims)
Somebody sent me those
tambourines, those are cool,
actually.
- Those are cool.
You know--
- Oh God. (laughs)
(crowd cheers)
- Okay, first of all--
- Oh God, you--
- Oh my God!
(Kelly and crowd cheer and clap)
- Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
That was to the "WAP" song.
That's a whole thing.
- Oh my God.
- That's a whole thing that a
friend of mine challenged me
to do it, but then yet I still look
like a fool, it doesn't matter.
- Girl, you don't look like no fool.
You look like the, (stammers)
if I had that body,
I'd be banging like that too.
(laughs)
I mean, like what!?
That was amazing.
- Thank you, I'll take that.
- Do you work out all the time?
- I work out a lot.
- Oh, that's why I won't,
see--
- Well, it's my sanity.
It's the kind of one thing that I have.
It helps my serotonin,
you know, in my brain.
It does, it really helps me so yes,
I do.
- No, I get that.
- I do.
- Mine is just sitting down,
talkin' with my girls, that's my--
- Okay, well whatever works.
- But mine doesn't get me
to thinner, so yeah.
(both laugh)
- [Lisa] We all have our thing, right?
- Yup. (laughs)
Rainn, do you do TikTok?
- I don't do TikTok, no.
I am too good, I'm too good
of a dancer.
- Oh.
(crowd chuckles)
People are known to tear
off their clothing to,
to tear it at their faces
when they see me dance.
- Yeah, yeah, they're so impressed
by it.
- It's provocative and erotic.
(Kelly laughs)
(crowd chuckles)
Yeah, so I'm staying
off the platform.
- And erotic.
- It's too dangerous.
- Thank you for that.
- That reminded me that
Antonio Mendez skit
where he was like, "Too
much, too much, Antonio."
Anyway, nobody knows what I'm
talking about, so (laughs).
- I do, actually. (laughs)
- Alone.
Okay, I was like alone on an island.
- Yeah, I do.
- Not my first time.
Well, tell us about your new beauty line.
I have some stuff here.
- Rinna Beauty.
Yes!
- Yeah.
- I'm so excited about it.
- Rinna Beauty.
(Kelly mimics blowhorn)
- I'm so excited.
We're starting with three lip kits
because my lips have had
a career of their own,
so why not make some money off of them?
- [Kelly] You know what, girl?
That's what I say.
- Right?
- This is beautiful.
I like this.
- Thank you.
Isn't it pretty?
- Yeah, what?
So you know what, the
names are all different
and you have a prototype right now,
so let's say you have birthday suit.
- Fancy.
- Right?
- Yes.
- We did three nude lip kits.
So you've got the nude, you got nude pink,
and you got new nude corals.
So it's really easy, really simple.
It's the colors I love.
- Oo.
I would love nude coral, that'd be pretty.
Nude coral's so pretty.
- Mm.
- And you get a lip liner,
a lip gloss, and a lipstick.
- That's so cool.
- Easy breezy.
- Yeah, well perhaps,
Rainn, you would like to,
I don't know, gift your
wife with some of this.
- I love that idea.
(laughs)
I love it, maybe she could
even put it on the brain.
I don't know. (laughs)
- Some nude coral?
- Nude coral.
- Yeah, anything
with nude coral, I'm in.
(crowd chuckles)
I'm all over it.
- You can have nude coral,
nude, or nude pink, or all three.
- Exactly.
- All of it.
- Great.
- Anything, yes.
Anything with the word "nude,"
anything with the word "coral," yeah.
- Great.
- I have a new thing on my vision board
and it's to hang out not
with you, but your wife.
(laughs) Hang out with your wife.
- [Lisa] I think that's gonna happen.
- I love her, already.
- I feel it.
- I feel a connection.
So where can you get Rinna Beauty?
- You can get Rinna
Beauty, it's on pre-sale.
11.15 on rinnabeauty.com
and 11/30, you can get it.
On November 30th, you
can buy all of the kits
on rinnabeauty.com.
- Wow.
Right on, all right.
Well Rinna Beauty launches,
like she said, November 30th.